because of a technical glitch last week
thousands of cell phone users suddenly
received text messages that had
originally been sent over eight months
ago on Valentine's Day did you know this
yeah it affected phones across multiple
carriers and it left a lot of people
very very confused I hadn't heard about
that that that was all like a mistake of
some kind apparently yeah
why did you did you get one of those old
Valentine's Day messages no no I didn't
I mean just tell us who's on tonight's
show dammit yeah I was going to it wait
if it's race everything all right inning
oh yeah just fine
hi one order of yum-yum bread that is $6
oh no it's actually it's free because I
got a coupon
so the youngnam bread is free yeah
that's a it's a valentine's day promo i
can't redeem it yeah but I just got the
text today so the yum-yum bread is free
I can't honor a promo that's over eight
months old I'm trying to be reasonable
but free young young bread is what I
want and free yum-yum bread is what I'm
gonna get
breathing
[Music]
: I'm sorry I was acting so weird before
um you want some yum-yum bread no thanks
sandy I've got my own
[Applause]
you